MARK: HELLO AMERICA, I AM
MARK LEVIN THIS IS A SPECIAL
LABOR DAY "LIFE, LIBERTY AND
LEVIN."
WHY DO THEY CALL IT LABOR
DAY WHEN EVERYONE TAKES OFF.
>> THEY SHOULD CALL IT
TAXPAYER DAY, HALF OF THE
COUNTRY DOESN'T WORK AND
DOESN'T WANT TO AND THE
OTHER HALF DOES VERY HARD,
TO SUBSIDIZE THE OTHER HALF,
WE'RE BUSY SUBSIDIZES
DEMOCRATS, OKAY.
I WANT TOON HONOR THOSE WHO
DID WORK AND MAKE THIS
COUNTRY GREAT.
THAT DO BELIEVE IN THE
CAPITALIST SYSTEM AND
AMERICAN SYSTEM.
YOU ARE THE ONES WE
CELEBRATE TODAY.
YOU ARE THE ONES I CELEBRATE
IN TODAY'S SPECIAL SHOW.
CELEBRATE WE HAVE GREAT
GUESTS THAT WE HAVE SEEN
THROUGHOUT THE YOU
WILL LOVE THIS WE START WITH
PETE HEGSETH.
ONE OF MY FAVORITE PEOPLE IN
THE WORLD, A GREAT PATRIOT, A
SMART AND NDA TIGHTER, HONOR,
YOU HAVE WRITTEN A BOOK THAT
IS SO GREATLY IMPORTANT.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU TIMED
IT.
BATTLE FOR THE AMERICAN MIND
UPROOTING A CENTURY OF
MISEDUCATION.
APPLIES TO EVERYTHING TODAY.
IF THE RADICAL LEFT HAS
CONTROL OF EDUCATION,
CAN-12, AND BRAIN WASH OUR
CHILDREN.
IT OVER.
WHY DID YO AU WRITE THIS BOOK.
>> I DON'T WANT IF TO BE
OVER, LIKE YOU.
I REALIZE ONLY AN EDUCATELI
THZEE POPULOUS IS A FREE
POPULOUS, THAT IS WHAT OUR
FOUNDERS UNDERSTAND AND
UNAND TH
YOU KNOW AND
THE LEFT KNOWS, YOU WROTE A
BOOK, "AMERICAN MARXISM."
WHAT WE HOPE THIS BOOK IS,
"AMERICAN MARXISM" FOR THE THE
CLASSROOM K-12,
HOW THE LUNACY YOU SEE,R
GJEN.
>> IT DID NOT POP UP OUT OF
NO.
IT IS A GRADUAL TAKEOVER OF
THE MINDS OF OUR KIDS,
YOU SEE IT IN LUNACY, YOU
MIGHT THINK THIS IS JUST
FROM THE 60S AND OR RADICAL
TEACHER UNION OR COMMON CORE
OR BARACK OBAMA, NO THIS IS
AN OVER 100 YEAR PROGRESSIVERD
PROJECT.
YOU KNOW DEWEY ANDVE
WILLARD, THE STRAIGHNTT
LINE FROM CRITICAL THEORY TO
ANTIFA.
MADE THEIR WAYS INTO FIRSTTH
THE CLASSROOM, AND
CURRICULUM BUT NOW OUR
STREETS, BREEDING A NEW
CLASS OF RADICAL LIFTIST
ACTIVISTS COMING OUT OF NOT
JUSTJU UNIVERSITIES BUT HIGH
SCHOOLS, MIDDLE SCHOOLS AND
ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS, WITH
THIS BOOK, I WANT PARENTSEP
ANTHD GRANDPARENTS TO KNOW THE
DEPTH OF THE PROBLEM TO BE A
PART OF SOLUTION AND
REORIENT HOW
THEY EDUCATE THEIR KIDS
FIRST AND ADDRESS THE LARGER
SYSTEM.
MARK: I SPEND A LOT OF TIMESS
STUDYING T THIS, YET I LEARNED
A LOT IN YOUR BOOK, IT
EXPOSES THE UNDER BELLY OF
WHAT HAS BEEN TAKING PLACES
IN THE CLASSROOM.
I WOULD ENCOURAGING PARENTS
AND GRANDPARENTS AND ERN WHO
CARES ABOUT FUTURE OF THE
NATION TO GRAB A COPY OFF
BATTLE T FOR THE AMERICAN
MIND.
WE WERE TALKING BEFORE THE
PROGRAM OF THE CLOSING OFME
THE AMERICAN MIND BY ALLENE P
BLOOM, HE FOCUSED ON
ELECTORAL
COLLEGE -- COLLEGES ANDATED
UNIVERSITIES.
IT IHROUS MY HOPE THAT BATTLE
FOR THE AMERICAN MIND, THE
FOCUS ON PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEM ON WHAT GOES ON IN
CLASS ROOMS AND HOW WE GO
THE TO WHERE WE ARE.OT
-- GOT T TO WHERE WE ARE THATWE
THIS RESONATES AS WELL.
IT IS IMPORTANT WHEN PEOPLE I
SHOW UP ON SCHOOL BOARD
MEETINGS THEY HAVE THIS
UNDER THEIR ARM.
IT IS VERY IMPORTANT. Y
AS YOU POINT OUT.VE
THERRE SAY REASON THEY PUSH
CRITICAL RACE THEORY.
A REASON THEY ARE ATTACKING
THE NUCLEAR FAMILY, THEY
DON'T WANT PARENTS INVOLVED.
YOU SAY THIS STARTED A T
HUNDRED YEARS AGO OR SO,
WHICH IS TRUE, WHAT WAS THE
GOALE O IF JOHN DEWEY AND THE
OTHER SO-CALLED EARLY A
PROGRESSIVESND?D
>> E A REVERSAL OF WESTERN
CHRISTIAN TRADITION, THEY
MASSED TURN IDEA OF MORE
VOCATIONAL TRAINING,ITIS
YOU NEEDED TO TRAIN THEM FOR A
AN INDUSTRIAL ECONOMY, A TO
FUTURE ECONOMY.
ALTHAT IS HOW THEY SPUN IT.
IN REALITY.
EVERY NAME LISTED IN THE
BOOK, THEY ARE ATHIESTS,
SOCIALISTS AND MARXISTS, IF
THEY WANTED RADICAL HUMANIST
CHANGE, A FUTURE UTOPIA OF W
WHAT IN HAA CALL EQUALITY, NOW
THEY SAY EQUITY, THE
CRUMBLING OF CAPITALIST
SYSTEM AND WESTERN STYLE A
REPUBLIC THEY HAD TO
UNDERMINE FREE THINKS AND
REPLACE KEY INGREDIENTS,
THAT IS GOD.
IT -- THEY KNEW THAT PARENTS
WOULD HAVE REVOLTED INHA
EARLY 20THT CENTURY, THEY
TOOK GOD OFF AND THEYAC
REPLACED IT,T WITH SOMETHING
THAT LOOKED JUST LIKE IT.
AND WHAT THEY REPLACED IT
WORK THIS IS SHOCKING FOR
PEOPLE WHO REVERE OUR FLAG,TH
AN AD COUNTRY, THEY REPLACE IT
WITH PATRIOTISM AND THE FLAG I
PUT IN A NEW PLEDGE OFE R
ALLEGIANCE THAT DID NOT
INCLUDE UNDER GOD.N
THEY CREATED A BRAND-NEW
NETWORK OF SCHOOLS, ONE THED
GARY B PLAN, IN GARY, INDIANA,
WHICH REMOVED GOD. I
FAST FORWARDN  80 YEARS, THEIR
PIPELINE OF PROGRESSIVE AND
MARXIST THINKING GOES THEY
NEVER CARED ABOUT ARE
PATRIOTISM AND HAPPY TO GET
RID OF IT IT, IT IS INCREMENTAL
STEPS FOR THE ATHIEST CHANGE
TOWARD HUMANIST AND
SECULARISM, GOES BACK TO THEO
MARXIS TT BATTLE.
THAT DONE WORK IN CLASS, WOR
WITH CLASS, THEY MOVED INTO
RACE.
AND GENDER AND MORE CULTURAL
ISSUES.
WILLARD WAS A SOCIALIST
FEMINIST WHO WANTED TO GET
RID OF ALCOHOL, SHE PUT IN
ANTI-
AL.
>> IN THIRD GRADE
CLASSROOMS, THERE WAS A BAN,SI
AND THES FROM ROOMVE IS MOST
POWERFUL TOOL WE HAVE.E
THEY STARTED TO CREATE NEW
SCHOOLS, THAT COULD DO THOSE
TYPES OF THINGS, THEY WROTE
ABOUT IT IN THE NEW
REPUBLIC, I WROTE THIS BOOKOU
WITHLD DAVID GOODWIN.
BIG PART OF RESEARCH WAS
LOOKING AT NEW REPUBLIC WHAT
JOHN DEWEY AND OTHER ATHIEST
PROGRESSIVES WERE TALKING
ABOUT, THEY OPENLY TALKCA
ABOUNT HOW IMPORTANTPR
EDUCATION WAS TOWARD THEIRIN
GOAL.G
THEY HADY T TO REMOVE GOD, THEY
HAD TO REMOVE THE
FREETHINKING ASPECT, THEY
BELIEVE IT IS THE SAME
CONDESCENDING VIEW OUR LEADSENDI
HAVE TODAY, AVERAGE PEOPLE,
DON'T NEED TO THINK ABOUT
PHILOSOPHY OR POLITICS OR
ECONOMICS, JUST GIVE THEM A
SKILL, TELL THEM WHAT TO
THINK, MAKE THEM GO AWAY,
THOS AE PEOPLE BECOME EASIER
TO CONTROL, IDEA OF A
LIBERAL ART, A LIBERATED
MIND, THAT IS WHAT THEY
WANTED TO GET RID OF.
>> THE BOOK, BATTLE FOR THE
AMERICAN MIND.
AT AMAZON.COM